I'm a really big fan of lots of your
work and one reason is because I feel
like you were just so good at
communicating about scientific ideas and
findings and broadening the conversation
more globally and it seems really
important that we all scientists and
science minded people get better at that
because there are all of these new
scientific things that are gonna change
our world in very big ways my fields
synthetic biology button artificial
intelligence and I can imagine augmented
sensation and all these other fields
like global warming Sciences where
people understanding and feeling
comfortable engaging the conversation is
like going to be really valuable for us
to be able to have a rational and
effective discussion as a society so how
can we all get better at communicating
about science and how can we as a
society move towards having more
rational conversations about
developments in science and and all that
great thanks for the cry is such a great
and important question I would say a
couple of things I know if you went to
graduate school grad school for your
grad school really beats it out of you
this idea of science communication when
I started grad school I would write
things in a way that I write them
currently and you know my mentors people
beat me they said it's not how you write
a scientific paper instead it gets all
you know what you wanted to be is all
jargony in that area is a bunch of
[ __ ] that I hadn't been unlearned
when I got out of grad school so one
thing is in teaching undergrads and grad
students I think it's critical to teach
them what you want is clarity what you
want is a way to say it in a way that
everyone understands but unfortunate lot
of undergrads or grad students are
taught the more confusing
you make it sound the more people would
be impressed and think you're really
smart
so if we get that part straight that
would help a lot happily there are so
many channels and venues for science
communication now in a way that there
never were before when Carl Sagan did
his show cosmos on PBS that was at least
to my knowledge when really the first
times that someone had done something
like that it was so beautiful but now
you go on YouTube a billion people are
doing that it's wonderful everyone's
doing you know whatever whatever their
field is or making little videos about
it what I've noticed is some of them are
higher quality science than others
sometimes people get things a little bit
wrong but at least there's a big effort
to have the conversation scientifically
I think it's really wonderful and and
again one of the reasons why six
generations just gonna be able better
off than we are because they could
access that stuff all the time thanks so
much for the question yeah I have a
question about bandwidth and like the
speed at which we can interconnect with
other people the speed at which we can
information can come in and how fast the
information can go out it seems like
your product would be like an iterative
step towards even higher bandwidths
where do you feel like you your
technology specifically the haptic like
sonic input transducer like where do you
think that fits in that in that curve
that exponential curve yeah thanks for
asking a question two things to say
about that one is when it comes to
things like AR as people think of it
with the headset that is using what I
think of as the software of the brain
like you know you're using the brain
software to read the graph or do
whatever it is so what what I think is
cool about this is it's plugging right
into the hardware which say you just
think it was part of your perception
that your direct feeling so I call this
AR it's just a different sort of thing
but in the answer to your question one
thing that I've been very interested in
trying we haven't done this yet but if
you want to do this with your spouse
where you feel each other's physiologic
signals so you'll you know the heart be
the Galvin
skin response blood pressure and so on
all that your feeling about your spouse
as he or she is walking around and you
guys are across the nation from one
another and you're plugged in you are
plugged into this other person in a
deeper way and then you can you know
you're on the other side the nation you
call up you say hey honey are you
feeling okay you feel a little stressed
out because I can tell something's going
on so I think it's a really cool idea
recently suggested hey why don't we do
that at work where everyone can feel
each other work I think it's a terrible
idea actually because I'm addressing the
question about how you get a higher
bandwidth an understanding other people
for example so you know but at work you
probably wouldn't want it because Bob
gets up to give a PowerPoint
presentation and Bob's really stressed
but he's trying to act like he's not
stressed yeah a big part of language is
about deception actually and so anyway
you probably wouldn't want to know who's
there but but I think there are all
kinds of interesting experiments to try
which we'll try over the next three
years five years with this kind of thing
about how can we really increase our
bandwidth and I mentioned before that
the communication channel between people
relies on on language and that's such
low bandwidth I mean the analogy that
I've started to use is if you remember
the Martian Andy Weir's book from the
Matt Damon movie where he's stuck on a
planet all by himself
that's essentially what I think it is
we're all on our own planet we're all
the the sole inhabitant of our own plant
and we just have this little radio
channel between us to try to explain
things so let me come back to
interstellar okay um so anyway this is
an answer to a question of how we might
increase that bandwidth between between
people thank you yeah thanks two
questions one given that our blames our
brains are plastic but yeah we have
limited
Pasi it's happened to are plasticity
what do you think the future holds for
either cosmetic neurology or neuro
modulation techniques and then also
being a neuroscientists where you what's
your explanation for the binding problem
yeah great questions I'll answer reverse
order so the binding problem is you know
I mentioned that you're getting
information through your touch through
your vision through hearings your stuff
and somehow we have a unified perception
when you watch a blue bird flying to the
left in front of you you don't see the
blue coming off the bird and the motion
and the sound and like it all seems like
one thing and yet it's so weird because
because these are all coming through
different channels so that's what the
binding problem is we don't know what
the answer is
one speculation has been that it has to
do with the timing of the cells firing
when you have a synchrony of cells
across different brain areas the visual
cortex and auditory cortex is on and and
that may be right but ask me again in 10
years and we'll see how that how that
data is coming along as far as the
neuroplasticity thing goes I think
there's a big unanswered question there
which is just a weird one which is you
know brains start off as very plastic
which means they absorb information they
change accordingly and that's why a baby
born in this country comes to speak
English and you know recognize the
American flag or whatever but you know
it absorbs everything about our culture
and all the science that's come up - as
you grow older the plasticity becomes
less and less so it's harder to learn a
language at our age and so on cool
things like cognition peaks at 23 and
then it just goes down over time well I
that's sort of the case that's off it
like Nobel prizes in physics usually
happen that age but that's for a
different reason which I can come back
to but but the issue is that plasticity
diminishes it doesn't go away you can
still like I said if you learn how to
juggle I can see changes in your brain
even as an adult and so on but but it
diminishes the key is this though you
actually want that you wouldn't want it
any other way because you become
who you are because of that so if we
went in and gave you cosmetic
neurosurgery to make you super plastic
again who you are and who all your
friends know you as a sort all that goes
away
all the memories that you've stored in
there and this where I grew up in blah
blah blah like yeah maybe there's
certain things you want to forget but
you would forget everything if we made
you're totally plastic in you would
remember how to speak English you would
remember how to walk you'd have to do
that again learn that again and so on so
anyway that's the interesting paradox
about plasticity that I'm chewing on
lately is that you know you sort of ever
there's an expression I can't remember
who said this so sorry but somebody said
every man is born as a thousand men and
dies as a single man which I find such a
fascinating statement which is to say
you've got so much potential when you're
born and you died as a single person but
I but again I think it would be well I
agree it'd be hard to have it any other
way I think David thank you for your
creative thinking oh you're probably
aware maybe not but there's an
increasingly popular movement in the Bay
Area to microdose with LSD I am oh okay
as a way of increasing creativity and
awareness so what's your thoughts on
that and or experience so I I i read an
early version of IL @ Waldman's new book
called a really good day and and it was
about micro dosing so she might be dosed
for 30 days and she's always that she
writes about publicly in the book I'm
not revealing it she's always had
problems with depression and sometimes
mania and you know just dealing with her
emotions and so on so her experience
over these 30 days was having a very a
much more stabilized sort of emotional
life and she said her husband who you
have to bet cousin noticed it and you
know their family notes and so anyway
you know I find it super interesting
when I blurb her book I'll just say that
I made sure that as a neuroscience
boring the book I said a very general
thing like you know this just points us
to the fact that we
so much more to understand and the
reason I was cautious about the
statement is because it's hard to know
if she has a really great 30 days is it
a placebo effect is it because you think
hey there's this really great new thing
it's gonna solve it's really hard to
know so I'm totally optimistic about
doing the science experiment which is
running as an experiment but ask me
again in a year good right I'm not
providing the LSD but there's no
shortage of in the Bay Area as far as I
can tell it so the yeah good I mean I
think microdose you know the thing is
there are all these psychoactive drugs
that have been illegal to try things
with to try things that are therapeutic
and so most of them probably won't yield
anything therapeutic but it's great that
we'll try them I think that's yeah
obviously it's the only way that to
discover any of you yeah thanks for the
question hi I have two questions so
artificial intelligence is a buzzword
these days and so when you read media
stories about artificial intelligence so
how reporters describe it as you know AI
is this technology that is loosely based
on brain so I work at a company where so
we have research scientists who
developed very leading-edge AI and they
don't like this kind of description so
you touch this finger talked a little
bit so do you think if we bring together
computer scientists is especially
machine learning a scientists and your
scientists together and work on AI
together
well these actually help advance this
field to the next level so my next
question so being someone who
understands how your brain works so well
I wonder if that changes your behaviors
your behaviors for example I was
listening to your talk and I have
I'm sure a lot of people in this room
can relate to I just can't help myself
thinking about or checking my phones
every now and then so owner for you know
someone like you if you know maybe when
something like that happens to you maybe
you think oh this is something my brain
doing on Trekkie I'm not gonna do that
so do you have any examples some
examples you know like how your
understand your brain changes your
behaviour yeah III can adjust it very
directly in fact this is good this is
gonna be my next next book which is I'm
sorry mostly done it's called the lyses
contractors I've spoken on this several
times which is how you started working
out what's that's how you work out you
work out with yeah that's how I work out
that's exactly right but what this
contract is about is if you remember the
myth of Ulysses Odysseus who was coming
home from the Trojan War and you've
realized who's gonna pass the island of
the sirens and he you know the sirens
were these mythical creatures who would
sing songs so beautiful that the sailors
would get entranced and then it crashed
in the rocks and died but Ulysses really
wanted to hear the sirens song but he
didn't want to crash and die so you may
remember what he did he filled his men's
ears with beeswax and he had them lash
him to the mast so that he couldn't he
couldn't do anything and he said no
matter what I do no matter what I'm
screaming so I just keep rowing past the
island and that way he was able to hear
the siren song you and not go - yeah but
of course they just kept drawing and
then they were safe but the point is
this is what has come to be called a
Ulysses contract because what happened
was the Ulysses of sound mind way before
they got to the island knew that he
would behave badly when he heard the
siren song
so he made a contract that was
unbreakable where the contract was okay
I'm gonna tie myself to the mass so that
I can't behave badly when I get into
that situation so I'm very enamored by
this idea of the Ulysses contract and
there were surrounded with these all
times so I think it answered your
question I've gotten really good at
Ulysses contracts because I understand
that there's parts of my brain that
really care about the short-term like
eating the chocolate cake and part of my
brains I care about who I want to be in
the long term it's
easy of course to think about who we
want to be but it's very difficult one
we're facing temptation and so the whole
trick is how do you structure things so
you don't face division just an example
is like in alcoholics Anonymous the very
first thing they tell you
clear all the outside of your house
because on a you know on a festive
Saturday night or a lonely Sunday night
you're gonna end up drinking it if it's
there and the house to just get rid of
it all if you're in a drug rehab program
first lesson is don't carry more than
twenty dollars of cash with you because
someone's gonna offer you drugs and if
you've got the cash that's burning a
hole in your pocket you buy so it's what
you do is you establish the behavior at
the beginning such that when you face
the temptation you know deal with it I
was speaking on a college campus a
little while ago and I found out that
what the students do there is they are
worried about logging into Facebook
during finals week when they're supposed
to be studying so they switch Facebook
passwords with each other and change the
password so they can't log in yeah and
it's very clever thing because they know
they're going to be tempted and so they
take care of that first and then when
finals are over they get the Facebook
password back sorry there's lots of
examples of this and that's the way that
as a neuroscientist I'd really come to
understand that I have lots of votes in
my head many votes are voting for the
stupid things and a couple votes away
from smart things so I try to structure
things so I can't not listen to the
smart ones as far as your question is
ness is a huge indicator of intelligence
it's why your ability to accept
contracts with yourself and execute on
those mmm long-term thinking I thank you
the yeah the the other question is about
should brain science get together with
artificial x researchers yes and that
people have tried that a lot the problem
is the AI researchers are sort of
looking for a hit like hey we do this we
can distinguish pictures of dogs from
cats or whatever and so the general
story tends to be the neuroscience come
in and say wow look we don't understand
XYZ ABC and the AI researchers come to
understand one thing and they say okay
great we're gonna go start a business
now see you guys later
so I wish there were a structure that
they could stay together longer because
I think it would be very fruitful hi
hold on to your question okay
so David I
let me put it this way I'm trying to
find the secret of happiness right the
the spiritual practices whatever I've
gotten information from right they all
kind of get into the same advice of
being in the present right being the
present moment this kind of touch I mean
simply put what I'm trying to ask is
from a neuroscience perspective does it
make sense when I say we cannot think
and feel at the same time like for
example if I feel something does it
force my brain to stop thinking the the
background behind the specialness like
all our troubles right all our problems
come from being in the time like being
in the future we are scared of it or
thinking about the past we are worried
about that right so spiritual practices
what they tell us is like when you bring
your attention to your body it is always
in the present moment and you cannot you
cannot really have your thoughts like
bother you right my question is this
when you feel something like anything in
your body does it force our brain to
like stop thinking that's so cool
question I can tell you this a hundred
years ago there were big debates about
how emotion and and thoughts and your
body interact with each other there's
essentially two schools of thought one
said look you know when you have a
thought that triggers an emotion that
makes your stomach tighten or whatever
and the other school of thought was when
your stomach tightens that's what gives
you the thought that you're anxious
about something and the question was
which was right and it turns out that
all got resolved it's both it's a big
feedback loop and it's not clear that
you can ever separate and say which
think came first which is actually
related something Ellen brought up an
hour ago which was you know where does
the thoughts start and with any thought
you have there's no T zero there's no
time zero that we can point to and say
that's what if I start in them instead
your entire life of every experience
that leads to the next thing in the next
thing so unfortunately there's no way to
say which leads to what
as far as happiness
goes no one's Senate better than then
our mutual friend a number of us named
Peter Bauman the good friend of ours who
he Peters expression is some days are
better than others and what he means by
that is that the brain always adapt to
whatever is going on of course you've
lots of studies about this you know if
you win the lottery you're really happy
but then after all you go back to your
baseline it happens if you get paralyzed
in a car accident
really sad after a while you go back to
whatever your baseline was it becomes
the new normal and so as a result we
always adjust to whatever our new
baseline is and some days are better and
some days are worse you know
yeah and anyway this I Peter has really
done a lot to convince me of this I
think he's totally right that that
happens the pursuit of happiness might
be impossible because we're just
fluctuating around our baselines ok ok
thank you so much thank you
so you said something very interesting
earlier you said that there's nobody
walking around the world experiencing
like seeing all the different
electromagnetic waves that you could
possibly be seeing in the whole spectrum
and such and it reminded me I I have
kind of done this so I took a FLIR one
camera which is an infrared camera
connected it to my phone put my phone in
a basically a little box put it at the
end of the box attached the box to my
head and then all I could see was the
phone rather than anything around me and
I walked around for a few hours just
sort of seeing around and seeing how you
experience the world like this
it was really weird and really
interesting but what I remember was just
looking at everyday things that you
would immediately recognize normally you
know what share of people you know
certain things I knew what I was looking
at roughly knew what I was looking at
some people I couldn't recognize or
whatever but anyone has a person for
example but there was this weird sense
in which
the person didn't like if you were
normally looking at them you would your
brain recognize them quickly as a person
etc in this case there was a sense that
you're experiencing the middle layer
right like you're experiencing like the
the salience of them is gone and instead
you're you're consciously aware of who
they are but you're not ingesting it in
the same way so I'm thinking with the
company that you're that you're working
on is it similar where you hear the bark
of the dog and you think okay that's the
bark of a dog but where you or I would
hear a bark of a dog we wouldn't think
that way we just look at the dog and
realize it's barking right like a
different conscious experience the when
does that fade when does that happen
like when yeah middle layer go away like
how many days what I have to walk around
with that thing strapped to my head for
that to happen yeah it's a terrific
question probably about four or five
days is what it takes so at first we've
grown you're like oh it's buzzing and
there's weird buzzing feeling and so you
can identify things pretty easily felt
like a self-wringing or dog barking or
whatever it is but it becomes part of
your just your conscious experience
after some days and depending on the
task you know cuz because right we're
feeding electromagnetic radiation in
there or whatever it's some things
probably take longer and shorter
depending on the task but that's the
weird part is that for all of our senses
we have this transition of course we
don't remember I did one of the chapters
I'm running in my book live why is this
issue about when when you're holding an
infant and it looks you right in the
eyes oh how wonderful it's looking me in
the eyes
I think the infant is not experiencing
looking at you the eyes at all like it's
completely a different reality to the
infant because all it's getting is this
barrage of spikes and it's figuring out
what the heck to do with that how it
correlates to other things and so on but
it eventually becomes a direct
perceptual experience just like we're
seeing each other here but it starts off
just like you with the infrared camera
the interesting part would be if you
wore it for for days and days or four
months let's say that in front of one
eye and your other eyes seeing this
world to see how those things merge and
that's essentially what
be trying that's cool they do that so I
have a few questions the first one
related to time being slower during an
event could that also be because you're
being present kind of like what was said
before where you're not thinking about
future or past but you're in that moment
so let me have said yes
it's when you're in the present that's
when you're laying down memories under
normal circumstances your brain is doing
59 things thinking about your shopping
list and what you need to order on
Amazon how are you getting home and your
brain think about 15 when you're falling
off roof you're thinking one thing how
am I gonna lay it you know like what
what do I do next and so so it is that
being in the present doesn't actually
make you see in slow motion but it does
make you write down everything that's
going on okay as far as the collective I
find what are your thoughts on sensing
energy and how does that happen in the
brain it's a great question there have
been a lot of experiments over the years
since the 50s and 60s and so on about
whether people can pick up on other
energy sources so far that's yielded
nothing so it depends what we mean by
energy but in terms of all the things
that we can think of like
electromagnetic radiation or the
frequencies in the hearing space or
whatever as romantic and ideas it is
there's there's not been a single
scientific experiment that actually
shows that to be true but you were
mentioning earlier to people having some
sort of a collective mindset yeah I so I
wouldn't necessarily call that energy
because I think it would be confusing
with what we mean and we've got a whole
library of things that we mean by energy
that is if our brain X is a mega brain
and so on that's a really interesting
neuroscience question about what happens
when you get all these neural networks
together acting like one neural network
but I wouldn't call it
yeah and so that is what I mean about
the hive mind it's it's actually like a
mega network but I just wouldn't import
the word energy into because we mean
something very different by energy okay
how does emotional trauma impact
plasticity hmm essentially I mentioned
before the amygdala which is the
secondary memory source when you're in a
murder situation so when people
experience trauma that gets written down
and the shitty part about amygdala
memory is it Sun erasable so other kinds
of memories can get a race under various
circumstances but amygdala memories
don't so so the best you can do if you
have a trauma is learn strategies to
overwrite that and when you think about
it immediately switch to thinking about
something else and so on but obviously
as a flag before the reason memory
exists is to write down when the
important stuff happens and that's why
when there's something emotionally
traumatic you really keep a record of
that remember oh okay I did it
you mentioned a story about University
students kind of a exchanging passwords
so that they could use Facebook less and
I was wondering what are your thoughts
on these a big technology companies such
as Facebook Twitter and Instagram that
have designed their products to be as
addictive as possible and how did what
are your thoughts on the fact that young
children you know when they're two years
old three year olds are exposed to these
highly habituated products where it's
because I have a two-year-old cousin at
the moment who is currently addicted to
YouTube and this baby knows how to sort
of scroll down all these thumbnails and
so forth and you also mentioned the pros
of technology right we are exposed to
all this information but at the same
time how do we deal with information
overload right so this question is
basically you know what are your
thoughts on the sort of
consequences that are coming from highly
addictive technologies and number two do
you is this something that we should be
concerned about or is this sort of a
natural thing that we will eventually
adapt to as human beings yeah these are
all good questions and this is sort of
these set of questions of our generation
of our era right now is trying to figure
all this out people are coming up with
different sorts of new ways that we can
think about approaches here and I think
there's a growing awareness of it as
well so that people even in the most
addicted places have an awareness of hey
you know what let's on Facebook set up a
face-to-face meeting go out to a coffee
go on a hike stuff like that in general
I've been thinking about this a lot and
I think that there's a part of it that
is not new as in everybody has always
been trying to set up everything to be
maximally addictive so when I walk into
a library which feels like I write this
real this is a library in fact every
author writing the book tried to make it
the best but possible to get my
attention to make me keep reading it and
so on you don't want to write a crappy
book that I put down right so
everybody's trying to make it the kind
of thing that you'll get stuck to and
Sears tries to offer the best thing and
Continental Airlines tries to do the
best thing with the the service or the
stewardesses so it's not really anything
new there and then the question that
everyone's asking is is it in fact you
know just a different degree of the same
thing which is I think the camper I fall
into as opposed to a completely new kind
of thing I mean the reason for arguments
completely new is you know there's data
and there's this and that but the fact
is advertisers have always been people
who are very clever about that they
don't need all that data to say hey if
I'm trying to sell this breakfast cereal
all you sexy people who are all laughing
and having a good time and that's really
what you need it's not like you can
imply some AI algorithm that's gonna
come up with something very different
than that so anyway I think I fall in
the camp of its you know of it but it's
not really a new problem that we're
dealing
and and in the same way that we all grew
up with television and newspaper ads and
magazine ads and so on that are all
trying to get our attention in
billboards whatever and we just deal
with it just becomes part of the
background radiation and in fact quite
good at prepping down a highway and just
sort of ignoring it like imagine you
came from a world I'd met he landed here
on from a planet where there were no
billboards you think oh my god you're
driving on the road everywhere you look
there's a sign for a business you must
be distracted you must get ADHD but what
we're quite good at this is not pay
attention we don't want to and I think
you know when people read the internet
you read something like CNN it's
completely smooshed up with ads but you
know you know where to look to get the
story that you want so I'm not so
worried about hello thank you for your
time
so I come from a complex trauma
background so and then the past few
years I've been very committed to trauma
healing and so there are three trauma
responses which in my understanding is a
fight flight freeze so I have a very
long conditioning which I freeze juh
trauma so even the traumatic events are
happen that Gates ago when my trauma is
a trigger then I freeze and I also get
dissociated right so when it happens
it's like the whole like we're all
stopped and then time stopped and I can
I even feel a sense of my body it's like
out of my body experience kind of things
but so and also jurors like erase trauma
when I started seeing a psychiatrist she
wanted me to they describe what exactly
happened that would kind of bring the
emotion that were not processed okay and
then I couldn't think of the event so
there was like him Lass's which
experience and then there was a like
reach Ramat izing expiry
well the memory started coming back and
then well I I've gone through it so got
the point where when the Association is
trauma trigger happens to me I have an
awareness that recognizing it and then
there's something I could do about it so
I've been there building some you know
tools included like somatic experiencing
and mindfulness meditation but it just
takes a very long time like would that
be would there be any I don't look could
be the ABS or neuroscientific I don't
know research or like in a scientific
way that like none none of a
psychotherapy could do could do that
that could like enhance trauma recovery
that would be hopeful yeah that's a good
question
I'm sorry for what you've been through
ie there aren't I mean people are making
advances in psychotherapy and doing
things they're trying out different
sorts of approaches that essentially
have to do with you know having having a
person be able to concentrate on the
future instead of concentrating on the
past so whenever you find yourself
looking in the rearview mirror you've
you know you figure out these ways look
forward so people are trying various
things but there's no trick yet in terms
of inserting Elektra we got a wireless
mic thank you
there are sort of because it's again
it's so important for the brain to write
down trauma that's why we get stuck with
this stuff last question over there
great okay so so the question has to do
with there's a debate in the literature
about whether we actually so this is a
separate issue about stuff streaming in
from the different thing you know when
you have your perception of I this is
what's happening is the brain actually
running discreetly every let's say 100
milliseconds it makes the decision and
puts things together we don't know the
answer to this yet I will say that the
evidence in support of that has been
undermined so it still may be true but
just as an example this is an example
[Music]
some colleagues of mine came out with
defining where they said look there's
the there's the wagon-wheel effect in
movies so if you ever if you see a movie
and there's like a car or a wagon wheel
it looks like it's running backwards
sometimes and that's because the frame
rate of the video camera and the turning
of the wheel is such that wheel turns
turns this yeah let's say the wheel
turns that much from one frame to the
next but but then it turns anyway what
you're catching is frames of the wheel
and that's why it looks like it's
running backwards the point is my
colleagues claimed look you can see the
wagon wheel illusion in real life under
continuous light where if you stare at
something let's say you have a record
player and you have this thing turning
on it you can actually see it running
backwards once in a while anyway my lab
did Studies on that and showed that
their interpretation of that was
actually not in support of discrete
frames of perception
it's a long story if we if we set up a
mirror so you're seeing the thing and
the exact same thing in a mirror they'll
reverse at different times which is not
what would happen if you're taking
snapshots long story short we don't we
don't know I don't see any really good
reason at the moment to think that
perception is discrete but it does
appear that other things like
decision-making may actually be discrete
like every 40 milliseconds you know the
brain runs a simulation of a turn right
or left here and then finally says okay
I'm gonna turn right here or whatever
but you can actually see at least in
rats that it seems to happen about every
40 milliseconds where you run a
simulation assess and then you run
another simulation to assess it so other
parts might be discrete this is the
weird thing about the brain is parts of
it are analog and parts of it are
discrete and at different levels you
might have both things going on yeah
okay our friend Terry remembered her
questions so I think ok last question so
David we've known each other for like
seven years at least yeah and thank you
for representing some version of reality
that's important to understand and so my
question is what confuses you the most
about reality at this point about
reality yes jeez it's this issue I mean
thank you for this such a good question
yeah and this is what led me to write
this book windows on reality it's it's
just this little amount we see and and
as you know from hooking up an infrared
camera and as you know there are cameras
for all different parts of spectrum in
different ways to see things and of
course supersonic hearing and if anyway
sorry I'm gonna challenge you a little
more in terms of like personal
experience mm-hmm not-not-not the
scientific I get you've got that tracked
but like your actual experience like
like you're you're a deeply embodied
human being who also has knowledge about
how thing
work and you also have the question
about questioning how things work on it
in addition to that so but like there's
some part of you that I love that so
alive and confused and I kind of wonder
I want to know what that is yeah got it
so you mean like my experience of
reality as opposed to yeah fine I mean
you want to hold us to the top ten it's
I mean just as an example every [ __ ]
night when I get into bed and I think
okay now I'm gonna stick my head in the
night blender of dreams and have all
these things that I take to be real and
and I'll be scared and I'll be happy and
I'll be thrilled and I'll wake up and
I'll say oh I guess none of that was
real and I'm back here we don't have any
explanation of what that's about
even so I think dreams is a big one and
just this issue even when we were
talking about businesses simulation you
know there's this possibility that the
simulation just began and you've got all
these memories that are implanted in the
sensation so I think I grew up here and
I went to this college above a lot and
and then like how the [ __ ] do I know
that's real or not real so yeah there's
really no end to the number of
confusions yeah and this is what drives
this is what drives the science last
last night I had a dream where you and I
were like laying in the same bed and
then it's so weird in minute and then
yup our dream girl this is and then and
then you tapped me to let me know that
something started wetting the side of my
head and I thought it was like a dog
peeing on me or something it was such a
weird dream it happened last night
what are weird simulation what a great
way to end this show
everybody for coming out please thank
you I got some I got some thoughts on
the way out so simulation series comms
where you can find us all this content
on YouTube and Facebook as well we do a
daily studio show featuring a lot of
these brilliant thought leaders across
different industries um later this month
we are going to be hosting two being
Jane we are looking to also host Jason
Silva at the end of this month it
spending still but it's exciting stuff
for us and then just keep keep checking
in kept keep looking and David Eagleman
books are all available on Amazon I mean
go to Eagleman comm and find them as
well neo sensory also be really tuning
in to what he's building with that and
also what is another important plug for
you oh yeah um well there's tons of
important plugs but anyway thanks so
much for tuning in these events can't
happen without you thank you work wise
for hosting please stick around network
amongst your brilliant selves as well
and huge thank you for coming out
tonight for this evening
[Music]
[Applause]